[Musica]
[Applauso]
gira girolomoni oltre che un pioniere
dell'agricoltura biologica è stata anche
un padre mio padre io sono uno dei tre
figli sono quello di mezzo essere figli
di un guru del bio
vi garantisco non è stato facile quando
eravamo bambini per noi
niente merendine al loro posto gallette
di riso o quando andava bene croccantini
di sesamo zucchero bianco mai visto
rigorosamente zucchero di canna grezzo
che raschia valagola panebianco con
quella famosa crema di nocciole neanche
a parlarne per noi l'alternativa era
pane integrale spalmato con una
meravigliosa crema di carrube però
questo crescendo ci ha dato anche
qualche vantaggio
ad esempio quando eravamo adolescenti e
volevamo mandare dei messaggi di
ribellione ai nostri genitori era facile
li minacciava mo che da grandi avremmo
mangiato i biscotti industriali di una
grande marca la più grande e così per
dispetto e per giunta che avremmo
mangiato la pasta della concorrenza
quella confezionata nelle scatole blu
voglio raccontarvi la storia della mia
famiglia di come è stata importante per
la nascita dell'agricoltura biologica di
come si è poi diffusa in italia
voglio dirvi perché il bio importante
per l'ambiente dirvi a che punto siamo
oggi e cosa potete fare anche voi per
aiutare la sua diffusione
io ci sono nato e cresciuto nel mondo
del bio accompagnando il mio babbo ad
alcune delle centinaia di convegni in
giro per l'italia a cui andava a
predicare il biologico costando nel
negozio di una mamma tulli romani uno
dei primi di alimenti naturali in italia
ad urbino dove ho visto un certo punto
arrivare anche le merendine biologiche
insomma ne ho vissuto l'evoluzione del
mondo bio sia in termini professionali
sempre più organizzato e precisi
ma anche come prodotti sempre più buoni
ho avuto la possibilità e la fortuna di
conoscere il vero sapore dei cibi senza
coloranti conservanti e aromi
artificiali
oggi i nostri genitori non ci sono più
sono venuti a mancare troppo presto
qualche anno fa
ormai noi figli siamo adulti e cerchiamo
di portare avanti i loro sogni
la storia del biologico viene divisa in
tre fasi 1.0 2.0 3.0 la fase 1.0 è stata
quella dei pionieri che avevano visto il
bisogno di un cambiamento radicale in
agricoltura
tra questi c'era mio padre che grazie al
suo amore viscerale e spirituale per la
terra aveva intuito la follia dell'uso
massiccio e indiscriminato della chimica
di sintesi in agricoltura pesticidi
erbicidi fertilizzanti di sintesi
antifungini e così via
ma perché fare a meno di queste sostanze
non è una questione di ideologia ma di
salute e sostenibilità salute perché
alcuni di questi pesticidi sono stati
poi classificati come cancerogeni
on è stato provato il loro effetto
neurodegenerativo il pericolo e
soprattutto per chi ci vive nelle zone
rurali ma la possibilità di trovarne
residui nei cibi e nell'acqua è comunque
alta sostenibilità perché innanzitutto
queste sostanze sono figlie
dell'industria petrolifera che come
sappiamo è una risorsa non rinnovabile
inoltre causano l'inquinamento di aria
suolo e acqua portano a un'importante
perdita di biodiversità che va a
danneggiare tutte le piante gli insetti
e gli animali insomma va ad alterare
l'ecosistema e questo a dirlo sono
sempre più scienziati e anche la
commissione europea l'ha riconosciuto in
un recente documento strategico
sull'agricoltura
per mio padre l'alternativa a questo
modello intensivo era l'agricoltura
biologica ci vedeva soprattutto
un'opportunità per ricostruire il mondo
rurale ma è dura la vita dei pionieri
per 17 anni la nostra pasta integrale
biologica si veniva sequestrata dai
negozi scrivere biologico nelle
confessioni era considerato frodi al
consumatore in quanto il termine bio non
era ancora previsto da nessuna normativa
e grazie anche le nostre iniziative che
poi sono arrivate le leggi
finalmente una normativa europea negli
anni 90 e la certificazione con la
certificazione e inizia la fase 2.0
dell'agricoltura biologica
la legge sul bio ci ha dato la dignità e
la possibilità di fare il nostro lavoro
così i settori si è sviluppato ed è
arrivata una vastissima gamma di
alimenti biologici
oggi siamo quasi 3 milioni di produttori
bio nel mondo dimostrando che quella che
era un'utopia derisa dai più in realtà
consolidata a 35 chilometri in linea
d'aria da qui da coriano da dove vi
parlo questo pia la potete toccare con
mano a montebello vicino urbino
abbiamo dato concretezza alla visione
che è possibile un modo diverso di
intendere l'agricoltura il suo rapporto
con la natura con il territorio e con le
persone di oggi sono il presidente della
cooperativa a gino girolomoni una realtà
di 400 aziende agricole biologiche con
quasi 30.000 ettari coltivati e che si
occupa di tutta la filiera dal seme alla
pasta la nostra esperienza è la
dimostrazione che non solo l'agricoltura
biologica è possibile ma anche che i
contadini se si organizzano possono
uscire dalla riserva nei quali i big
dell'industria agroalimentare li
vorrebbero confinare e anche la
rivincita del mondo rurale che era stato
abbandonato
in un luogo dove anche i campi erano
incolti oggi ci lavorano quasi 70
persone un antico monastero che era
distrutto stato ristrutturato
c'è una fattoria didattica a cui
partecipano scuole da tutta italia è un
accoglienza agrituristica in cui vengono
persone da tutto il mondo
oggi il biologico sta vivendo la fase
3.0 che consiste nel portare il bio
fuori dalla nicchia per farlo diventare
la normalità dei consumi delle persone e
crediamo che questo possa contribuire
alle tremende sfida del pianeta e della
nostra specie in questa fase il
biologico sta crescendo e allora senso
rus si inseriscono le grandi aziende
la grossa distribuzione le
multinazionali posso immaginare quello
che avete in mente ma sarà tutto bio
la paura è quella di spendere di più per
qualcosa che non ha il valore dichiarato
e di sentirsi fregati io non sono qui a
fare il sindacalista del mondo bio corso
semplicemente raccontarvi quello che si
fa a casa mia
venite da me aprite il frigo la dispensa
trovate solo prodotti bio non solo i
nostri ma anche di aziende che non
conosco personalmente perché nonostante
da operatore riconosco alcuni limiti
della certificazione per me sapere che
un prodotto e bio è importante ed è una
garanzia importante e così ho deciso di
nutrire mio figlio mentre mi sento molto
più fregato da quelli che sostengono che
i pesticidi entro certe soglie non fanno
male senza che nessuno abbia mai
studiato l'effetto che il cocktail di
pesticidi ha sulla salute nostra e su
quella dell'ecosistema
stiamo andando però nella giusta
direzione la commissione europea ha da
pochi mesi pubblicato un piano decennale
per far transitare l'europa verso un
modello alimentare sano equo e
rispettoso dell'ambiente
questa strategia si chiama from farm to
fork dal campo alla tavola e ha tra i
suoi obiettivi quello di far diventare
biologici il 25 per cento delle
superfici europee entro il 2030 dicevo
stiamo andando nella giusta direzione ma
troppo lentamente
abbiamo un countdown un conto alla
rovescia e dobbiamo accelerare
e per farlo dobbiamo ripensare i nostri
stili alimentari al rapporto che c'è tra
città e campagna tra chi consuma chi
produce anzi dobbiamo capire la
differenza che c'è tra consumare senza
criterio e scegliere con criterio
mio padre in una delle ultime interviste
rilasciate disse pratico e di fondo
l'agricoltura biologica non tanto per
salvare il mondo che è un'operazione
difficile e che non spetta a noi ma è
per non stare dalla parte di quelli che
il mondo lo distruggono
lui è stato definito un profeta del bio
e aveva l'autorevolezza per dirlo io
sono solo uno a cui in fondo sono
mancate un po le merendine da piccolo
però continuerò il mio impegno
quotidiano e personale a portare sempre
più persone verso il bio ma anche voi
potete fare
potete fare la differenza e dare il
vostro contributo
semplicemente decidendo di fare scelte
informate in campo alimentare per voi e
per la vostra famiglia prediligendo
alimenti locali agricoli e biologici
[Applauso]